if we didn't separate artists politics
in the artist we would lose a lot so the
Italian futurists became hardened
fascists as her pound wrote some really
good things the road was a lot had a lot
more approval of Stalin than most of us
by us I guess I mean me would so the
first part of the question can you
separate her artists work from his
politics we do the answer to this can
you is yes we do all the time and all
the more so historically so that you
know Shakespeare's ideas about Jews
they're not it's not a political matter
its cultural matter and there's an awful
lot we would deprive ourselves if we
start bringing the template of our own
political convictions to art on the
other hand when you're making art we're
doing the art of your own time arts
indifference nothing's forbidden to it
she can't so this is to political or its
politics indeed to ignore that aspect of
life is to restrict your subject matter
an awful lot just speaking for myself I
don't think I have to become an expert
in constitutional law or an expert in
American and foreign policy to feel the
desire to express the emotions I feel
when I read the newspaper and I try to
do that as well as I can and then it's
somebody else's job a year later or
fifty years later to decide whether I
did
stupidly or in a way that was moving or
absorbing
people locations the audience will
always there always would be an audience
for a cliche sometimes for great work of
art not you know Melville ruined his
career he was popular for a white jacket
and people wanted another white jacket
he probably could written one probably
would have become tried by Jack it's a
pretty good book it's not Moby Dick but
he was popular his publisher loved them
he had a readership and he wrote this
crazy book about whaling and nobody
could read it nobody could sell it it
was such a big flop that it wrecked him
to bed effect on his life you know he
suddenly was a very unsuccessful writer
all you can try to do is try to do
something fresh I don't believe there's
anything that in theory somebody
couldn't write about well there's no
forbidden subject you know great comics
can make anything funny art is
omnivorous you never know when you might
write a great work is it always a the
pitfall of the tried or the
self-important or this or that or the
banal yeah sure and in fact as a
Melville's case sometimes everybody's
wrong now usually if somebody says none
of them liked it they didn't get what a
big genius I was he probably didn't even
say that sometimes it's true we need to
catch up to it we don't understand and
the very literary critics who write
about John Keats or Gerard Manley
Hopkins or Melville I hope they think
the equivalent of me and recognize
Keith's the equivalent of me did not say
this Gerard Manley Hopkins is something
extraordinary the equivalent people had
their attention elsewhere
and I think that all the time no I read
poems submitted to slate where I'm an
editor I say well I have to assume that
it's possible that Emily Dickinson
Hopkins's in here and i'm not i'm going
to see it